what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the imposter batman the
imposter and this is the conclusion
we're wrapping the whole thing up uh
would you guys really seem to enjoy this
i mean the videos perform somewhat well
but those of you guys who love you guys
were just really die hard about it
then you really wanted to see how it
ends so here's the thing about this
right um in the last video we kind of
ended things where flanagan was kind of
this guy right this rat catcher who just
never really got any respect from
anybody and uh the only real friend he
thought he had was batman simply because
batman had saved his life somewhere
along the line and so what ended up
happening is that in a skirmish with
batman that basically flanagan was
beating it was beaten up right i mean he
was just kind of assaulted by uh by
batman and that's where his tone begins
to change because he doesn't understand
why he was abused by somebody that he
thought was a friend right why he was
beaten up by batman from someone he
thought was a friend and the reality of
this is that the batman who saved him
was well we just call him robert
pattinson right i mean he looks just
like him so we can just say it was
robert pattinson batman uh the person
who beat him up was the imposter but
flanagan doesn't know this right the
only thing that he really offered to
pattinson's batman is he basically said
there's all kinds of sewer systems and
it basically revealed at one point in
time uh that the imposter batman was
basically using the sewer systems and
essentially had a layer down there
somewhere and so what ends up happening
is you basically have the partner of
blair who comes in and starts offering a
more heavy-handed interrogation like
kind of like a good cop bad cop sort of
situation and what this does is it leads
to the two of them or really to to
flanagan himself kind of mentally
breaking just due to the fact that his
life has just really been in the tanker
for quite some time he ultimately takes
the gun of blair's partner and then offs
himself and so at that point you switch
over to bruce having his conversation
with his therapist and it's one of those
things where he was talking about
flanagan having this this making this
comment about uh there being like a
hideout in the sewer somewhere or
something along those lines putting two
and two together he realizes it's the
imposter he was referencing to and that
ultimately uh flanagan has said that he
said it was behind a waterfall right and
then ultimately bruce wayne kind of
deciphering and looking through all
these things says well there's there's
basically 11 vertical drops in the sewer
system one of them will lead me to the
imposter and he says i'm gonna go down
there and what's really interesting is
the therapist doesn't really care so
much about batman or about bruce wayne
tracking down the imposter what she
cares about is bruce wayne's mental
health and she says you lit a fuse with
the gotham city police department
tonight when you launched an attack on
them in order to get your hands on
flanagan right it's it's only a matter
of time before it blows up and that
ultimately bruce doesn't really care he
just kind of ignores that and he's like
i had to get to flanagan i had to hurt
her i had to assault detective blair in
order to in order to get the information
that i needed and that's something that
really seems to weigh on him right this
idea that he had to go after the woman
that he cares about and had to
physically assault her in order to get
to flanagan it's really interesting
because one of the things that goes on
with this version of bruce wayne and
this alternate reality is that he seems
very emotionless when the reality is
he's exceedingly emotional and so
following that you basically go directly
into uh into his whole really
investigating the sewer systems and
ultimately tracking down this waterfall
and then essentially stumbling across
the base of the imposter now the reality
is he's been going at this for hours and
this is really like the last one which
basically seems to be uh well i mean it
seems to be paid her to be honest
right he got exactly what he was looking
for he manages to pick a lock and
essentially start looking through or
rummaging through the various weapons
this guy has at his disposal only to
find out or only to have the imposter
basically show up behind him and a fight
breaks out between the two of them now
this fight is really really interesting
because whenever we think of bruce wayne
fighting as batman in the main dc
universe he's batman right so he's able
to like almost always overcome whatever
foe he's facing off against uh unless
we're talking about earth to batman and
then he blew himself up but the thing
about this is that in in this story it's
really designed to give us this
depiction of bruce wayne who's very
unpolished who's very very basic who
doesn't really have the kind of skills
and things that you would expect to see
him have and so the results of this is
that because he's not quite at the bruce
wayne that we normally expect when this
fight goes on you would expect him to
come out on top but what he basically
says is they end up you know falling
into the water and and so on and so
forth as he says this guy's fast right
and this guy's strong which basically
means he's just gonna have to hit him
more he can't overpower him with
strength so it's basically gonna have to
turn into kind of a war of attrition but
the reality here is that bruce wayne
can't really gain the upper hand what
ends up happening is that in the midst
of this fight suddenly these cops all
basically show up and that's when bruce
realizes okay this had to have been some
kind of a setup this person had to
either inform the cops or been a cop or
something like that in order to in order
to basically orchestrate an assault in
such a way to where he could show up as
the imposter batman he could fight me
and then while i while this is basically
a distraction the cops appear in an
effort to basically you know capture me
and get me out of there and so what's
really kind of nuts is that of course he
uses a flashbang of course and is able
to essentially make his escape and then
ends up on a city street and because of
the fact that he's injured he ends up
just kind of making his way getting to
where he can when he can and so on and
so forth and then of course recovers
enough in order to use the various you
know ropes and whatnot that are around
gotham city in order to get back here
but again he's still being chased once
the cops realize he's there there's a
helicopter all kinds of stuff and then
ultimately he is basically tracked down
by detective blair and then once blair
gets to where he is and then begins the
process of like unmasking him to find
out what's going on she realizes that
it's bruce wayne now something to
understand here with this is that while
blair sees this in one part at least in
terms of her professional part as okay
bruce wayne is the batman the batman has
basically been killing people as far as
we're aware we have to arrest this guy
on a more deeper level and on a personal
level it's a massive betrayal it's a
huge betrayal here because the man she
loved physically assaulted her right and
because of that it's one of those things
where that's why you see her crying
right because it's literally like i care
about bruce wayne bruce wayne assaulted
me right which means bruce wayne never
cared about me in the first place now he
does try to plead his case in saying
like batman doesn't kill batman does not
kill people the imposter is the one
who's dressing up as me and killing
people and in the end where he's just
kind of like he basically goes to leave
she initially says like no you're under
arrest and that's when the question is
like either you can put me down or i can
leave but there's no other option if i
am off the street you're never going to
catch the imposter batman and the
imposter is going to kill people so let
me go so i can stop this guy and then
we'll basically call it a day and so
what this does is it leads to a bit of a
story where he still has the shotgun in
his possession that he had originally
taken from the imposter he kind of goes
through and starts analyzing it and says
okay so here's the thing this gun
basically has a squid on it and he tells
us the story of a guy named lawrence
lohman that lawrence lowman wanted to be
a kingpin that he was the son of a
chinese real estate magnet and he came
to gotham city looking to take over the
problem is that as you guys know from
reading batman comics unless you're
somebody like the joker or something
like that that people just know not to
mess with just because of either how
crazy you are or if you're the penguin
how much power you have that loman
didn't know that and he basically
started calling himself the squid and
then branded every single every single
thing he had with the squid insignia not
realizing it was only a matter of time
before somebody tracked him down
ultimately they did and then ultimately
loman was basically put away but before
that happened there was a shipping
manifest that basically documented all
these weapons these pistols 450 of them
in fact they were being sent to gotham
city and that what he realizes or at
least what bruce realizes is that each
one was safely locked away by by the
gotham city police department in their
evidence room but he found a gun that
was basically branded by the squid and
the the lair of the imposter batman and
that's when batman realizes the imposter
is a cop right this guy's trained he has
access to the prison lockup he's got
motive to kill the people who have been
killed so far and the cause for why they
were killed right the judge in that
instance and basically blame it all on
batman the guy's a cop who is
essentially killing criminals that were
seemingly let out onto the street for
any number of reasons and he's gonna pin
it all on batman in order to make sure
that he gets away scot-free it's a
pretty genius concept because no one
really knows what's going on with batman
and so of course he ends up basically
visiting blair and then tells her the
person's a cop like the the imposter is
a cop they have access to the prison
lockup i'm not saying it's you i'm just
saying it's a cop so here's what you
need to do you need to go and basically
visit the morgue or any number of those
those scenarios you need to dust
people's fingerprints and then you need
to compare those fingerprints to the
murder weapon and then in turn that's
when you will find out who the cop is
that's when you'll find out who that
person is batman of course can't break
into the prisons and to the police
station and do all that himself
otherwise i'm sure he would in the main
dc universe he would but you know i'm
not necessarily sure he would here in
this particular universe but the thing
about this is that kind of following
blair to a degree and even this
conversation uh that she has with bruce
wayne it's one of these things where she
basically confirms like you know yes
like your suspicions about this being a
cop was true i don't know exactly who it
is but she says like the prince that i
took they're in a safe place and it's
only a matter of time before those
prints are basically um identified and
we could tell you exactly who this
person is and the very least verify that
there is an imposter batman pretending
to be you and going around and killing
people but before that can happen
there's a red dot basically a sniper
that's aiming for blair and then
essentially shoots her now she doesn't
die right she's basically alive here
she's just you know severely injured and
of course where batman ends up going to
save her the impostor arrives on the
scene manages to shoot batman or at
least injure him enough to where he's
temporarily out of commission and then
goes to kill blair and so of course a
fight breaks out yet again between these
two or at least not necessarily a big
huge drawn out fight but enough where
batman's able to get a batarang off and
basically injure the impostor before he
can kill blair basically stabbing me and
stabbing him in the eye which is kind of
nuts his mask ends up coming off and
that's when you discover the imposter
batman is actually the partner of blair
right now we don't really know exactly
what his motivation is but he does
explain it here right he basically
spills the beans in this whole thing and
essentially saying that with batman
right with everything going on with him
the reason why this was done is because
of the fact that with with bruce wayne
or he doesn't really know he's bruce
wayne but with batman operating in such
a way to where he basically rounds up
criminals and then drops them off in the
you know at the police station who in
turn basically arrest these guys that
between that and between the crooked
judges that it was only a matter of time
before somebody came asking questions
and basically revealed that these guys
were denied due process that batman
doesn't have the authority or the right
to operate as a vigilante round up
criminals and then drop them off with
the police station and then let the
police take it from there because the
reality is at least according to how
this law is kind of being depicted here
the police did not not witness the
commission of a crime and there's no
other witnesses to those crimes aside
from batman but batman's a vigilante and
so the question is if person a is
breaking the law and in doing so
witnesses person b breaking the law and
then hands person b over to the police
does that in turn allow person b to be
arrested but the argument was at least
in the courts anyway batman denied them
due process and so because he had
assaulted them he never read the miranda
rights or anything along those lines and
then in turn you had corrupt uh corrupt
members of the judicial system that
basically all those convictions were
overturned and so this guy is blaming
batman as well as the broken judicial
system for how things turned out his
intention was to track down all these
criminals who were released kill them
all and then blame it on batman and then
basically walk away from there that even
if bruce wayne died somewhere along the
line because batman is so ambiguous and
because no one really understands his
motives because commissioner gordon's
not there anymore and even if
commissioner gordon was still here had
he not been run out of town his word
wouldn't necessarily be trusted because
of his previous actions and because he
was forced out of town then ultimately
people would only really see one batman
but they would still assume it was the
same person and that once this guy was
done he could just simply walk away from
the batman mantle and everybody would
just assume batman's gone now and that's
basically it his mission completed and
so because of that of course this guy
was basically killed you know when he's
knocked off the building falls to his
death and that's basically the end of
him and then in turn you end up having
this kind of conversation between blair
and bruce wayne that where blair is
ready to arrest him and take him in for
the things that he'd done he says okay
like i had rules i thought they'd
basically be enough i was wrong but he
then he asked her the question do you
think that gotham will actually be
better off without me if you believe
gotham city will be better off without
me here operating as this batman then
arrest me take me in the the billionaire
here it'll basically be a day and
there'll no be there won't be any more
batman right your career will be made
you'll be set for life and so on and so
forth he says but if there is a part of
you that believes that that the city of
gotham will be worse off without me then
you have to let me leave you have to let
me go you can't you can't make me stay
here because you'll be basically making
the city worse and in the end blair lets
him go and it's really really cool the
way that it's done because in the
aftermath of all this while the the
therapist of you know leslie tompkins
could have you know easily handed bruce
wayne over to the cops ultimately she
didn't and bruce wayne knew she wouldn't
do it the loyalty between the two of
them and her being able to understand at
least to some degree how he got to where
he is and why he does what he does in a
lot of ways it's really her kind of
justifying it and saying that gotham
city really is better with batman here
batman can operate within a way that
people just at least the cops themselves
just normally can't is it going to take
a bit of finessing and is he going to
kind of have to like get his act
together and operate in a better way
yeah definitely but in time batman won't
necessarily become somebody people trust
but he'll become something that the
judicial system actually begins to build
around and work around not only that of
course the copper the partner of blair
is basically implicated as like the
false batman and so on and so forth and
that's essentially it but nonetheless
it's one of these things where the story
itself is phenomenally done because the
last little tidbit we get is basically
the ventriloquist right we had talked
about him earlier in the stories this
guy who ends up going on to become the
ventriloquist read everything that he
hated about his life and every ounce of
control that he wanted to have is all
kind of manifested in the form of like
his ventriloquist doll but instead of
becoming the villain that we know there
was a previous point in time when he had
encountered batman and batman had
actually given him the number of leslie
tompkins and said you need to go visit
her right you need help the things that
you're going through are going to make
you a dangerous person you're going to
end up hurting people i know that's not
what you want to do so you need to go
and contact her and so of course
basically giving him this kind of note
that doesn't have anything but the
batman symbol on it leslie knows what's
going on which is a great concept
because instead of leslie being a
medical nurse like she is in the main dc
universe albeit with another part of
therapy going on there that instead
she's actually a person who's here that
instead of batman like pummeling these
criminals beating them up you know and
then throwing them in jail so they can
only escape yet again he actually hands
them over to her so she can basically
study them diagnose them help them
overcome the problems that they're
dealing with and then in turn return to
society as productive members it's a
genius idea it kind of turns the nature
of the batman mythos on its head a
little bit nonetheless uh that's it guys
this is the end of the story i loved it
it's phenomenal it's probably one of the
best batman stories that i think i've
read in a long long time and i'm not
even gonna lie the alternate reality
batman stories are just ridiculously
enjoyable i enjoy those more than i
enjoy the main batman stories it's just
it's nuts and it's it's it's great but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace